the session this morning will be chaired
by miriam
okay so i'm very happy to announce the
first speaker which is eric cavalcanti
and
he will
tell us about semantics for
counterfactual in quantum causal models
um
please go ahead
thank you um
it's a pleasure to talk to you today
it's a real shame i couldn't be there in
person
but because it would have been great to
share in the discussions which i'm sure
have been very interesting and because i
haven't been to berkeley since 1999 when
i was an exchange undergraduate student
there
sorry if i may be a bit slow it's 2 30
a.m here in australia but uh i think uh
hopefully okay
so today we were talking about this
joint work with my student adra
cluterius rash and my postdoc marcus
friends
on the semantics for counterfactuals in
quantum console models
and uh this work was
partly funded by an arc future
fellowship
and the large grant from the
foundational questions institute
okay can you also see the screen
yeah
so let me start with a story
when i was a small kid we used to live
in a
high-rise apartment in rio de janeiro
brazil
much higher than in this picture
i often looked out the window and i
wondered
if i were to jump would i fly
and at some point i was convinced that i
could it's bad influence from some tv
shows and one day when i was maybe two
or three years old i put a superman cave
pushed the couch next to the window and
with the help of my sister was 11 months
older than me and climbed up and i was
ready to jump i think
and my mom arrived just at the time and
what are you doing and my sister said
he's gonna fly
and then commotion and my father arrived
and said why don't you practice first
from the table and so after several
unsuccessful
practice jumps and maybe some bruises i
decided that i needed more practice
um so i remember that night having a
vivid dream and i was looking out the
window on the same spot my mom didn't
come so i jumped
and then i crashed
and it became a recurring dream remember
having that for many years
uh and that's probably why i remember
that story really you know it was so
small and i gave that gave up the idea
of flying of course they say that one of
the purposes of dreams is to simulate
the effects of our actions
they can't affect your effects or
actions and i think this isn't true to
that
in my case at least it was certainly an
evolutionary advantage i could say
so let me ask you had i jumped
would i have flied
and i hope all of you will agree that
the answer to the question is no
so conflictual questions can be
meaningful and they appear routinely in
everyday record discourse
and we make intuitive judgments about
them
questions like what if i had jumped what
if oswald had not killed candidly
even that the patient died what if they
had not been given the treatment some of
these questions are may determine life
and death and maybe it may determine
um
praise and blame or
medical
you know mistreatment trial
or
even
more importantly what if we stopped
emitting greenhouse gases
so but the semantics of kind of factual
questions has a controversial history
one of the most
cited early accounts and not the first
was due to david lewis
he proposed to evaluate counterfactuals
by a
similarity analysis of possible worlds
and that's
following also proper stomacher
and um he said a kind of factual if it
were the a then it would be that c
is non-vectors lead through even only if
some accessible world where both a and c
are true
it's more similar to our actual world
overall than it is any world where a is
true but c is false
now he also said conflicts are infected
with vagueness we ordinarily resolve the
vagueness of chiropractors in such a way
that counterfactual dependence is
asymmetric and then he proposes a system
of priorities
to resolve this vagueness in terms of
possible worlds i'm not going to do
anything like a full review
um
and what about causation
the beginning is often quoted as
identifying
conversation with mere regularity or
doing a way of causation altogether but
as pointed out by lewis he defined
causation in two ways as a regularity
and also as counterfactual dependence he
said we may define a cause to be an
object followed by another and where all
the objects similar to the first are
followed by objects similar to the
second or in other words
where if the first object had not been
the second never had existed
and so lewis
said i take human second definition as
my definition not of causation itself
but of course of dependence among actual
events and the proposal kind of factual
analysis of causation
and it assumes determinism it must be
noted as also does his theory of
counterfactuals
now cutting a long story short to get
close to the topic of this workshop
counterfactuals feature at the top of
judy apparel's ladder of conversation
paul's work identifies a hierarchy of
progressively sophisticated models that
answer progressively sophisticated
questions at the bottom of the ladder is
the level of association related to
observations and statistical relations
advances questions
such as how would seeing x change my
belief in mind
and the second rung
is the level of intervention which
consider questions such as
if i take aspirin will my headache be
cured and the final run is the level of
counter factors
which is associated with the activities
of imagining retrospection understanding
and they consider questions like
was it the aspirin that
stopped my headache
and power has argued that levels two and
three are particularly important for
human intelligence and energy
understanding and they are crucial
aspects of our modeling the world and
the effects of our actions and he also
argues that some current artificial
intelligence higher impressive is true
level one of the hierarchy of the
statistical association and that's the
little robot there
maybe arguable but that's that's no
considering now the
common age of quantum computation one of
the motivations for this work is to
extend build analysis to the framework
of quantum code models which
may have potential activity for quantum
ai but more importantly i think
it is i think an interesting fundamental
and philosophical question
so level one association
is
in call which encodes a statistical data
there is a probability distribution
over various variables
and probably distribution can always be
encoded as some bayesian network which
is a directed acyclic graph representing
statistical independence relations
and the distribution is said to be
markov relative to a graph
g
if it is possible to factorize
distribution in such a way that its
variable
is conditioned only on its parents in
the graph but in general there will be
many bayesian networks which are
compatible with the same probability
distribution so here's some examples of
factorizations or quantization graph
and that at this level the graphs don't
carry causal meaning they're just a
convenient representation of the
independence relations
at the level two of the hierarchy we
have the causal bayesian network so here
the errors
between the nodes and called causal
relationships so a causal network is an
oracle for interventions it includes the
possible the potential effects of
interventions
that an agent may do in the system so a
due intervention intervention where you
set the value of say variable a
to a given value the lowercase a
is
calculated by this truncated
factorization formula which can be
conceptualized as this mini surgery in
the graph which because
the error is going into that node which
is being intervened upon and setting the
value of the variable the node to some
specific value so here's the graph for
g and here's a graph that you get if you
intervene on g
to
set a to be equal to a
in the level three we have
structural causal models for
probabilistic structural models if the
probabilities are included so this
consists of a dag with a set of
endogenous variables here the
a
b's
of exogenous variables u which uh which
can be thought of as local noise
variables which are determined only by
factors outside of the model
and
a set of functions that determine each
one of the variables as a function of
its parents in the graph and its
corresponding
exogenous variable
and a probabilistic structure across a
model also has a probability
distribution over the exogenous
variables and it's easy to see that
a probabilistic structural causal model
induces a causal bayesian network over
the endogenous variables by
marginalizing over the exogenous
variants
now in temporal metaphor
sorry um now pearl's
three-step algorithm for counterfactuals
now
evaluates a kind of factor as a um
uh in terms of a structural causal model
so a counterfactual in the question of
the type given evidence e what is the
probability that y would have been
that y had x being little x
and so paul
proposed a three-step algorithm to
calculate that which is composed of
abduction action and prediction in the
abduction step we update the probability
distribution for the association's
variables by the evidence
to obtain the probability of u given e
in the action step we replace the
equations for the variables in x and the
set of variables by a particular value
that's doing a 2 intervention and in the
prediction we compute the probability
for y
using this modified model
and in temporal metaphor the step 1
explains the past the exogenous
variables
in light of the current evidence
step two
minimally bends the course of history to
comply with the
hypothesis with the antecedent or the
factual and step three predicts the
future based on a new understanding of
the past and not
nearly established
condition
so notes now two similarities with
losers
analysis here counterfactuals are
evaluated assuming determinism
and so counterfactuals have well-defined
truth values
and a minimal deviation from actuality
is implemented
to satisfy the intercedent
now one important distinction from this
is however lewis causation is explained
in terms of counterfactuals for po kind
of factors are explained in terms of
causation and here i take
the same
perspective the same
point the same
approach
uh
explaining color factors in terms of a
quantum cosmology
now so far so good but now as we all
know quantum theory um
throws a spanner into x
by a number of noble ethereums that show
that
classical causal models cannot explain
certain quantum correlations
while satisfying a number of a priori
reasonable
assumptions the most well known of these
is about zero which can be stated as
showing that classical causal models in
particular the
representation of color structures
attack and the causal markov condition
together with relativity called a
structure for a particular scenario here
being say alice and bob in the space
like separate lab x and y being choices
of settings and maybe the observed
outcomes and lambda
for specification of the common causes
um
and if we also assume that intervention
is a choice to desire exogenous they
have no relevant causes
we obtain the bell inequalities and
thereby contradiction with quantum
correlations the contribution with
observed
data
regardless of of quantum mechanics
um okay so that's
one
issue
and another um which might may not be
well known for those who were not
working in quantum physics in particular
in quan foundations
there's also a
more recent
novel ethereum by chris wood and rob
speckins
who showed that if you you don't even
need to assume the particular causal
structure that i showed in the previous
graph that comes from relativity if you
assume
uh if you want your your causal model to
satisfy the assumption of no fine tuning
or faithfulness that is that conditional
independence is
must arise as a consequence of the graph
and not due to special choices of
parameters so for example if we have no
signaling we should expect
a
causal model
which does not have causal paths between
the setting on one side and the outcome
on the other side
so assuming no fine tuning there is no
possible graph which can explain the
quantum correlations
and as i as many of you know the that
assumption is important in causal models
to allow in general for causal discovery
um and then in 2008 i proved a stronger
result based on that and without you
extra assumptions from wooden speckiness
and also largely generalized to contrast
back and texturally but that's not
important for the present purposes and
more recently with my student
j pearl not to be confused with judeo
jesper
we proved another result in full
generality
so one alternative of course is to
accept the violation of large physical
salary
of faithfulness and to accept that
cholesterol cannot be discovered in
general
very recent years a growing number of uh
of papers have been produced on the
topic of generalizing the classical
cause of model formalism to accommodate
quantum correlations in a way that's
compatible with productivity causality
and that allows for causal discovery and
faithfulness
so this has led to development of
frameworks for quantum causal models
which two uh here are like highlighting
red
some of the more
complete which can be probably called a
framework for quantum console models
and this work will be based on a mixture
combination of features of these two
formalisms
and by the way um
sally shrapnel and john barrett are both
talking about their work at this
conference i believe
but unfortunately on the last day and so
uh would have good to have their
introduction to it but since that wasn't
possible i'll give a brief review of
quantum clause models but if you want to
learn more stitching for their talks
okay so what is a quantum causal model
in a class because a modular node
represents obviously a classical random
variable in a quantum
cause of modern nodes are conceptually
very distinct they are a locus of
potential interventions
so
a node a here he has associated with it
a pair of hubert spaces which represent
the input system and the output system
to that node on which an intervention
can be made
and in this work we assume like in the
framework of of barrett and others that
the dimensions of the hybrid space are
the same as in order to allow for the
possibility of doing no intervention
having
in the in that node
and a quantum instrument
is a set of completely positive maps
that sum to a completely positive trace
preserving map
so here i represent
the choice of instrument by variable z
so that's a set of cp maps and the
outcomes are labeled by lowercase a
and if you sum those cp maps it comes
with cptp map i don't label the
instrument with this m
because in general the same cptp map may
have a decomposition in terms of many
different
instruments
now the the key technical tool of
quantum cosmos models is that choice
chasm office
we use a version of the cj isomorphism
which is essentially the same as that of
costa and shrapnel
because it's simpler to understand i
think
but we use the notation of bearing
lawrence barrett lawrence and irish code
because it leads to a
simple statement of the quantum version
of the causal markov crunch
and the similar formalisms have been
developed in the various terminology
multi-time formalism quantum columns
process matrices etc they're all talking
about similar things in the
different uh individual contexts
so the trojan merkovsky astronomer is
associated through every cp map so here
this m a given z
a positive semi-definite operator which
is called a tau a given set
which lives on the tensor product of the
input and output for hebrew spaces
and it can be thought of as
the stay up to normalization the state
you get if you prepare a maximum
entangled state between these two hybrid
spaces and then you apply the cp maps to
this subsystem
and if you sum these
operators then they sum to
the
choi operator corresponding to a cptp
map
and one property is that if you trace
the alt output system because the trace
preserving map it gives you an identity
on the input
all right so now let's consider channels
between nodes they say we have a node a1
and node a2 and a channel
e from the
space of linear operators on the output
hub space of a1
to the space of linear operators on the
input hyperspace of h2
so this is a cptp map a channel
that takes
states from a1 just states on a2
and
when it is quantum channels
between nodes that we are talking about
the
cji is amorphism gets an overall
transpose relativity definition for
instruments and this is a convention so
that the probabilities
in the bone rule or the generalization
of the bone rule like even by a nice
looking role without a trace
trace is going all over the place
so compare these this is a general
transpose
relating onto the other all right so now
quantum process operator
sigma over
the nodes
is a positive
semi-definite operator that lives on the
tensor product of
all these hilbert spaces
such that for all choices of instruments
at the nodes so this is a cptp maps
the trace of
this object here
is one
and the probabilities for observing the
particular outcome of these instruments
a1 2 etc given choice that one etc is
given by this generalized bond rule it
has much the same form as the standard
bond rule if you think of this as as a
state and this is a measurement operator
and the similar objects go by various
other names like i said quantum columns
in the course and shrapnel formalism is
called the process matrices
and here we use this shorthand notation
the trace of a means the trace of a and
a out
all right so now a quantum causal model
is specified by a directly exactly graph
g with quantum nodes a1 etc
a quantum channel for each node that
goes from the parents on the graph to
that node
such that all these channels commute
and the process operator is given by
a product of these
these channels
and
this is the quantum cause of markov
condition now note the analogy with the
factorization formula
for the classical cause of markov
condition that's my reason to prefer
this notation
now now consider the toy operator for
our unitary channel
from
input from keyword space a b to hubert
spaces cng
okay
yeah not necessarily associated to nodes
just in general now
we say that
that
a does not influence d
if and only for any state row b that's
prepared if we have we're preparing
product states here for any state row b
that's required it's not possible to
send signals from a to d by varying the
state at i
and this can be given a more precise
mathematical definition but that won't
be necessary for this talk
now a recall that in the classical case
the kind of factors are evaluated
relative to a structural causal model
which is represented by a set of
functions associated to the nodes
and exogenous variables associated with
each node
in a structural causal model we have
full information about the process
and we all lack of information is about
the values of the variables at the
exhaustion nodes that's where the
probabilities come in
so we defined then the conversion of the
structure
causal model analogously is a dagger do
you have a set of quantum nodes a set of
exogenous
nodes there's a final node f that's not
showing the figure
there will be errors
potentially from all the other nodes to
it so they'll be constant
and an cherry um
detroit jimmy kovaci
isomorphic
operator corresponding to a unitary
from
the um
outputs of a to the inputs of a and from
lambda you have
that satisfies the no influence
conditions that you can see um
represented in this graph
each um
each node
is only influenced by its parents and
each lame down influences its local
local nerd
and a set of preparation instruments
which we can think of as
an instrument which with probability p
of lambda
prepares a state rho lambda
in the output of the uh
the exospons
and that just ignores the input
so now summing over the elements of
these instruments we have a a an
instrument that prepares the state row
which is this particular mixture
to the composition of the secondary
now why how do we decide what is the
preferred basis what do you prefer the
composition for these exogenous
instruments
um
this is an assumption that the
assumption is that that comes to the
model the similar issue arises in the
structure how do you decide what are the
the the exogenous variables it may come
from various physical reasons for
example maybe because of the coherence
maybe because
we know that there's some setting on the
laboratory device that
as essentially but we don't know the
outcome you know the particular
operation
from some other reason that the reason
may be but the idea is that there should
be some effect of the matter so these
should be for all practical purposes
classical variables it should be stable
facts
to use the terminology of uh
dbi and revelli
so the motivation for introducing this
type of instrument is so that
just like in the structural course and
water
now all lack of information about the
process is attributed to a lack of
information about events
physical events
at the exhaustion stones
and
now these are the variables of which we
perform the
the abduction step for the evaluation of
the color factor
now we say that our process operator is
compatible with a dac g and uh there's a
slightly different definition in
in uh
bert at all
uh if and only if there exists a quantum
structural model associated with g
that recovers that process operator
as a marginal
okay
and it can be shown and also that
follows straightforwardly from this
proof in uh for this different
definition that sigma a is compatible
with the graph g if and only if it is
markov
now their slightly different definition
is in terms of our unitary process with
inputs which is almost the same
as our quantum structure model with the
crucial difference that in that
definition there are no instruments at
the exogenous nodes these states are
thought of as being part of the process
there are no events associated with
those states whereas
here we want to think of those as being
physical events that we we can imagine
that
there's a fact of the matter at least
for all practice about which one of
those events has happened and it's
something that we can
make inferences about interest
so here we are allowed we were able to
do a protection
now the proof yeah as i said follow
straightforward
now
given the information if we knew about
all of these outcomes for the actual the
events at exogenous nodes
we can define a conditional process
operator this is following
cost and shrapnel
which is the pros operator for the
endogenous nodes that we get conditioned
on
knowledge about the outcomes at the
exogenous mode
and
note that this is only well defined in
general because the exogenous nodes have
no causes
so this probability in the denominator
doesn't depend on the instruments that
are performed on the endogenous lines
and so this can be used to calculate
the conditional probability for a
particular set of outcomes for this
instruments given lambda
just by
the generalized bond rule with this
conditional process operator and here
i'm using this notation with a bold
letter a and z
to represent this tensor product of the
instruments that call the nodes
all right
um how much time do i have sorry
i think about 10 minutes left
okay
so now let's consider the evaluation of
kind of factors
in pulse
formalism as we've seen a kind of factor
statement can always be assigned a true
value
if you give a full specification of the
exogenous variables
so one can define a probability for the
counter factor to be true
as the probability that the the u's the
the
background variables lying in the range
of values
where the kind of factor is value is
evaluated as true
in a quantum structural model on the
other hand a counterfactual will in
general not have a true value
even given a full specification of the
background conditions
and of course that's because quantum
mechanics in general doesn't give
purifies to statements about potential
outcomes
um so that means that we can only
generally ask for the probability for a
counter factor it should be true but
rather we can only ask for kind of
factual probabilities
in some cases there will be one or zero
but not engine
so the most general kind of factual
carry that we can answer unambiguously
in this formula
is what we call the standard factor
querying which is the following given
that the set of instruments z
has been implemented and outcomes a
obtained
what is the probability
that outcomes c would have obtained for
a subset of nodes
had instruments at prime being
implemented in outcomes b obtained
at subset of notes b
and uh
notice that to get an ambiguous sentence
we need in general to specify
the instruments in all nodes both actual
and counterfactual if that's not
specified in the query we may
decide to interpret that as as putting
an identity instrument as putting a no
intervention
but that must be a specification
even if it's not intervention
all right so now um
yeah we could also include a case where
we have partial information about the
observed outcomes but it should be
obvious how to treat that cave so the
notation would be clunky for the stroke
so didn't do that
now given a quantum structural model we
this can be evaluated similar to pills
method
three-step process of abduction action
and prediction
so for the abduction step we want to
infer what the plasmas have been
the stable facts given the information
that we have present so we want to
update our information about the
outcomes of these instruments
uh given the observed outcomes at the
various nodes and because all of these
are effectively jointly measured
variables
we can perform bayesian update
to calculate the conditional probability
for the lambda given i and given that
the instrument sets have been performed
so just do bayesian inversion we
calculate the probability for a given
lambda using that conditional process
operator that introduced probability of
lambda that doesn't depend on that this
is the prior probability
and the probability for a is just given
by
the
generalized bond rule
and so you can define an updated
process operator which is just a
weighted
mixture
of the conditional crossovers
with
the
with the updated distribution for the
background variables
so there's analogous to
pearls
modified model
now for the action step we modify the
instruments at the endogenous nodes too
as required by
the antecedent of the counter factor now
unliking pearl's formalism we do not
need to modify the process itself we
don't need to break errors because an
narrow breaking intervention node can
always be emulated
with some appropriate
discard and prepare instrument
management that discards the what's
coming the input and prepare some state
at the output which states this depends
on the question we're asking how into
that
now finally we calculate the prediction
for the required conditional probability
using now the updated process operator
with the count factor instruments the
instruments corresponding to the
counterfactual
query
um
okay um
and so here again
this notation is a
shorthand for a
tensor product of various
instruments elements
so if a factor can be interpreted as a
standard query of this form then you
will always have an unambiguous answer
as a book but sometimes it's not and so
next and that's part of the ambiguity
that the vagueness that lewis referred
to we will discuss the task of
interpreting that kind of actual period
that's not already in standard form
so in in parallels formalism all kind of
factors are evaluated via a jew
intervention
and here we are allowing room to have
kind of factors where the action step
does not correspond to intervention in
fact it could even be trivial and why
well
in a classical structural model
given complete information about the
background variables all endogenous
variables are determined
so this means that the only way the
antecedent could have been different
while keeping the background fixed is if
some intervention had occurred so pearl
said to model an action juxtaposed works
one performs a mini surgery on the
causal model there is a minimal change
necessary for establishing the
antecedent while leaving the rest of the
model intact this means surgery not
unlike lewis's little miracle makes
precise the idea of using a minimal
deviation from actuality to define
counter factors
now in a quantum structure model even
giving complete knowledge of the
exceptions variables and complete
knowledge of the process having an
energy process does not in general
determine all the instrument outcomes so
the intercedent could have been
different even keeping all of the
background variables fixed and keeping
the rest of the model intact
if the instruments are the same and the
probability of having obtained
the
the
outcome corresponding to the student
is
non-zero for all
values of the background variables which
are non-zero
given the evidence
okay so now we call a passive kind of
factor
one that can be evaluated without
requiring an intervention where these
conditions are matched
so
for example consider scenario where i
have two endogenous nodes b and c
and the next i'll just node lambda which
is just this preparation is when it
repairs with probably a half a state
zero probably a half state one
and
say the instruments that b and c are
just measurements on this plus or minus
basis
and the
the units are just an identity from line
to b from b to c
now it asks given that b equals plus
what's the probability that c equals
plus had it been that b equals minus but
now the probability
of getting the problem of lamb the given
b equals plus is larger than zero for
all lambda and the probability of
getting plus is large and zero for a
lambda as well so
we can't answer as a kind of as a
passive kind of factual and then the
answer is that the probability of
getting c equals plus given had c
it's equals but it had big being equal
minus
um is zero
okay uh since i don't have a lot of time
i'm going to have to go a little bit
faster here now we can consider a
slightly modified model where the
preparation is in a different base it's
preparing the same state if you ignore
the outcome but now it's in the plus and
minus
so now those conditions are not
satisfied
and
the only way to accommodate the
intercede now is via an intervention so
we use
geointervention
which just prepares the uh the state
minus
at the output and ignoring
so that's the analogue integration but
and so we can answer this kind of actual
query which in this case turns out to be
zero um it could have chosen different
values that it could be different
now note that this is very important
that this due integration is not the
same event in the sense of not being the
same cp map
as the original one
so
there's there's definitely some veganism
degree there about whether there's
deriving genomics in a sense analogous
to
intervention
impulse mode
now how do we decide whether
a kind of factor should be interpreted
as passive or exactly why not just use
the active version
and the reason is that uh the motivation
as we're sawing poe and it lewis is that
we want to make a minimal modification
in the actual state of the world to
consider ultimately the closest possible
world
and the closest possible world is one in
which everything was the same but it
happened the outcome is cheaper
so we can propose a principle of
similarity if it is ambiguous whether a
kind of factual query is intended as
passive or active and it can be
interpreted possibly then it should be
interpreted as a kind of actual question
so i could see this case of el scenario
i have two nodes a and b and a common
cause c which just prepares with 70 uh
maximum entangled state
so the the channels effects rise in that
way and alice and bob say it is
measuring on the computational basis
now given that a equals zero what's the
probability that
b would have been one
had a being one
so by the principle of similarity we
should interpret as a passive count
factor because it's possible to do so so
the answer to that would be that it's
one so a
and b it would be perfect correlated
which is what we find so here then in
fact the counterfactual had a true value
b would have been one had a being one
um
but notice that there is no cause of
dependence so unlike you say in lewis
confectional analysis of causation here
kind of effective dependence does not in
general imply causation
now if you were to interpret that as an
active kind of effect you would get a
different result we get that there is no
dependence between uh a and b if we do
interpret it's in a two operation at a
but again this is further from
the meaning of the outcome having had
being a because it would be a different
event
so
and that was a further from the actual
world because it requires intervention
so there's a good reason to that is a
passive contractual that just means we
get to a different conclusion about the
relationship between counterfactual
dependence and causation has lost it
and let's build it
uh now just to complicate things a
little bit further there's also a class
of counterfactual queries which consider
can't affect consider the counterfactual
instruments in your decisions so it
shouldn't be should be classified as
active
but the kind of factor instrument is not
a jew intervention so you may call this
active observational conflict or i don't
love this technology it may change
itself um
so
yeah so here for example imagine that we
have that uh the counterfactual
were the alice could have performed a
different experience a measurement on a
different basis so we say what's the
probability that you have would have
been one had it been that equals one
that's one that's apparently b would
have been one had been that a equals
plus there is that alice had measured
this difference you can obtain it on
first that probably would have been a
half so there's a counterfactual
dependence
but that's conditioned on the outcome if
you didn't condition on the outcomes
just ask was it probably that because it
had this definition being used then
there wouldn't be a conflict of
dependence so one of the things that we
know there is that conditioning on
outcomes can create a kind of effect of
dependence without cause dependence
if the conflictual instrument
does not block the input to the node as
it does in a two intervention
um
okay now in summary then we defined a
quantum structure model and a semantics
falcon effect was an analogy with those
and we find that in quantum causal
models the relationship between conflict
of dependence calculation
which exists in lewis and and power is
broken now kind of factual dependence
may occur without cultish
and kind of actual dependence is
associated with cause depends only for
active kind of factors for
for kind of for
those which include a
something like a do intervention
now some limitations of this model first
it's not intended as a general theory of
kind counterfactuals it's not going to
answer what would have happened if
arsenal didn't kill kennedy it's
obviously only
aimed at questions about one experiment
um very hard to answer
other kinds of questions with that
and also different interpretations of
quantum mechanics would have even
different answers for example in
biomechanics
it's a deterministic theory so something
more like both analysis would be
would be
implied by that the difficulty there is
that um
we cannot
know exactly what the
the causal structure is in chin
now another limitation is that quantum
cosmologists do not resolve the
measurement problem so this is something
that i argued in this paper 2016 and
then more recently
in this paper without wires and there's
a talk
that i gave you recent uh
in a recent workshop which is based on
this noble theorem uh
from
uh our group at griffith on the veganist
friend paradox
so if you just
watch the talk of
that and so the upshot is that um the
classical
and quantum causal models are
we can think of them as very effective
theories they are pragmatically useful
they have different levels of
description classical causal models are
useful in the classical limit and
quantum cosmos are useful when for all
practical purposes we can say we have a
fixed size in background with quantum
systems on the side
and classical systems on the other side
and we can and biggest we identify the
outcomes of
of the interventions
so some further questions is there's a
there's a
long his debate about
the idea that quantum mechanics violates
kind of factual deafness which has been
discussed in very vague terms again it's
an interpretation dependent question but
within this interpretation of kind of
factors
you can be given a more precise
statement of what it means to to to
violate conflictual definitions
um
also which animation they their
relationships with uh things like
contextuality
and um
also i i looked at very simple
cases with not very interesting uh
answers in this talk but could there be
more interesting applications of that
for example in cryptographic scenarios
would i have observed something
different had that been an eavesdrop
and also more general more interesting
calls and networks
thank you
thanks very much um there are some
questions in the room so i think we'll
start here
um thanks can can you go back to the
pearl's ladder i think it's
11.
you went by
yeah there
so this is something that just bothered
me about pearl
and and i just want to get your uh the
way he has that set up just literally on
the page
yes you have some kinds of systems that
can only
do association okay so they're just
doing
statistical analysis of observed facts
right and that's kind of clean
and then you've got the next step up the
doers
which are cavemen somehow
and then the imaginers right and and
it's by these three levels now it seems
to me that just isn't right for the
following reason
um and and it's connected with another
piece of terminology so
their subjunctive can be pure
subjunctive conditionals
if x were the case b would be the case
which are
uncommitted as to whether x is or is not
the case so yes and then there are
a i'm going i'm conflating kind of
factors with subjects and there's
contrary to fact conditionals
counterfactuals where
implicitly you're asserting the
antecedent wasn't the case yeah sure but
if you're a doer right if you're
interested in practical decision making
what you want to do is evaluate pure
subjunctive conditionals about what
would or might happen were i to do
action x or were i to refrain from
action x yeah and compare those things
and then make some choice
but
that means you're already
answering questions about pure
subjunctives now if you if you think
you've got the pure subjunctive if i
were to jump out the window i would fall
and you don't jump out the window you're
committed to believing if i had jumped
out the window i would have fallen right
so the pure subjunctive commits you
if you accept give it a truth value it
already commits you to the
counterfactual in the case where the
antecedent doesn't actually obtain
so this whole picture of there being
these three steps arranged in that way
isn't right doers must be imaginers
because you have to imagine the
consequences of different possible
actions
yeah so i think this whole picture gives
you a wrong
the wrong architecture for how things
go because it suggests that you need you
need something more than intervention to
get to the counter factuals but you
can't do the intervention part properly
without doing essentially committing
yourself to counterfeit
yeah and i think i think i think that's
that's a fair point um i don't take too
seriously the interpretation that is
being there are certain kinds of agents
that can do one thing but not the other
but i think we can certainly interpret
that as some kinds of models that can do
one not the other and that's
what i discussed here um and
i think bo is taking perhaps
his particular hierarchy of models as
somehow standing for
agents out there in the world which have
those models in that mind and as you
point out that may not be a clear
constitution
okay so
maybe i can ask something as well so i
was wondering about kind of the context
of of
uh this framework you've you've been
presenting so do you think because you
mentioned bohmian mechanics and that
different interpretations would have
kind of different notions
so do you think it's the the main
application of this will be in kind of
the foundational aspects of
understanding theories or do you think
um it's also a framework that that you
would see used in in
applications for instance for
understanding experiments or so
i think
at a
first
instance i imagine that it will be more
useful as a pragmatic tool
in the same way that classical causal
models are useful as a pragmatic tool
and there's a lot of people in these
audiences they use classical chords and
models if you know we know that they
must be false right because of better
qualities
that doesn't mean they
they're not useful
right and and likewise
i think if we are talking about say if
we have
quantum agents trying to decide
about um actions involving
kind of factual questions or
interventions
involving con systems
something like these models will be
pragmatically useful whether or not
they
correspond
to
you know could they correctly correspond
to the ontology
even if bone mechanics is true we might
still
code our quantum ais with something like
these these tools to reason about
quantum systems in the same way that we
may
code our classically eyes with
classical cause and motors to reason
but yeah and as i mentioned
we already know that quantum
cosmologists have a limitation and need
to be taken seriously as a
foundational model for conversation in
the world because of the measurement
problem called things like fitness
friends
scenarios
but i think an interesting question is
whether they can be extended they can be
modified i have seen since in a
relational sense
um they're maintaining some features of
the formalism but the main features of
the phones
in the same way that quantum cosmos
models have extended classical
cosmonauts i imagine that it could be
something different that would be a
further extension um but they would but
if it were useful you would be using
very remote kind of situations but
potentially if one day we have um you
know
large quantum computers with running
complex ais
in superstitions of different
observations etc
uh something like that might be
those might be useful for those kinds of
agents for us
including those agents
but that's a speculation
um
yeah then potentially something like an
extension that could correspond to
to uh
let's say a correct description of code
structure in the world
but again that's speculation
thanks very much i think um time is
already quite advanced so maybe we
should thank the speaker again and and
if there are more questions
maybe feel free to to get in touch
directly